[Música]
economía aquí en directo américa en
francés 24 me acompaña en el estudio
jorge hurtado jorge muy buenas noches
vamos a comenzar en américa latina' allí
el peso colombiano tuvo una histórica
caída frente al dólar lo padecemos en
los bolsillos nosotros bueno santiago
durante la jornada de hoy el precio
mínimo en el que ese negocio fue de 4
mil 470 pesos y el máximo al que se
negoció fue cuatro mil quinientos
ochenta un precio histórico sin duda
alguna solamente 20 pesos de diferencia
para llegar a los cuatro mil seiscientos
el aumento del dólar frente al peso es
cercano al 15 por ciento desde los tres
mil novecientos del 19 de junio
precisamente cuando gustavo petro ganó
las elecciones colombianas a nivel
global el peso colombiano es la segunda
moneda del mundo en depreciarse más
frente al dólar la primera es el rublo
de rusia y a nivel de américa latina
ocupa el tercer puesto en depreciación
algunos prevén que para el tercer
trimestre el dólar rondará entre los
4600 a los 4 mil 700 pesos por dólar
para moderarse a finales de año en
4200 pero esto va a depender mucho del
comportamiento del petróleo del precio
del petróleo a nivel internacional y
sobre de la situación política interna
los expertos recuerdan como durante
anteriores crisis económicas el dólar
subió en torno a 800 pesos en 2008 el
aumento del dólar frente al peso
colombiano fue del 50% en 2020 para la
pandemia de coronavirus ese aumento fue
del 30% y en los últimos dos meses ese
aumento va por el 15 por ciento pero
porque está subiendo el dólar frente al
peso de colombia se lo preguntamos al
economista andrés moreno y esto nos dijo
dólar en colombia hoy tuvo un nuevo
máximo histórico llegó a
4.580 por primera vez en la historia por
encima de 4500 la razón básicamente es
que a nivel internacional todas las
monedas se están devaluando frente al
dólar el euro el yen las monedas
latinoamericanas
eso es un primer factor y eso ocurre por
los riesgos de recesión que hay en la
economía a nivel mundial incluyendo eeuu
y adicionalmente por las alzas de tasas
de interés en eeuu ya subieron en julio
van a volver a subir tasas de interés en
junio que se vuelve mucho más atractivo
para los inversionistas estar en este
país que están en países emergentes como
colombia entonces un entorno
internacional un petróleo cayendo en
menores expectativas económicas debilita
la moneda colombiana también localmente
hay tensión pero qué está ocurriendo con
la política y un cambio que viene y
encontramos fondos internacionales que
no quieren todavía entrar a colombia y
colombianos sacando su dinero del país
es una combinación de factores
seguramente en estos momentos la que más
pesa es el factor internacional pero
también hay factores locales que hacen
que el dólar esté tan empujado hacia el
alza bueno jorge el peso chileno también
se ha visto muy afectado frente al dólar
en los últimos días los chilenos así lo
han reportado también vamos a hablar de
otra divisa que también está cayendo
frente al dólar y es el euro llega a su
nivel más bajo en 20 años bueno
nuevamente el dólar se acercó a la
paridad con el euro por la preocupación
de que una crisis energética lleve a la
región a una recesión el dólar continúa
impulsado por las expectativas de que la
reserva federal de eeuu sobre los tipos
de interés más rápido y en mayor medida
que sus pares europeos o del mundo otro
factor de esta caída del euro se debe a
que el mayor gasoducto que lleva gas
ruso a alemania el nuestro y ninguno
comenzó su mantenimiento anual y se
espera que el flujo se detenga durante
al menos 10 días el índice del dólar
alcanzó los 108 19 puntos del nivel más
alto desde octubre del 2002 se espera
que la reserva federal de eeuu suba los
tipos de interés en 75 puntos básicos en
su reunión que se va a realizar entre el
26 y el 27 de este mes pues ya lo estaba
diciendo yo en chile el peso chileno
tiene allí ciertos problemas y por eso
el presidente de public boris anunció
que va a destinar 75 millones a 7.5
millones de personas ayudas porque la
inflación también está generando
problemas en la economía de ese país
pero eso es ayuda antes deben ser
aprobadas por el parlamento porque
anunció la extensión del ife laboral un
subsidio el empleo hasta el tercer
trimestre además de la ampliación de la
ayuda económica y posnatal que está se
extiende hasta 60 días también se
entregará un bono invierno equivalente a
120 mil pesos que son unos 120 dólares
por persona a unas 4 millones de
familias pertenecientes al 60% más
vulnerable al país chile aprobó más de
40 mil millones de dólares en ayudas
desde el inicio pero los últimos 12
meses el país acumula una subida de
precios del 12.5 por ciento el nivel más
alto de
1994 en total ayuda económica será de
1.200 millones de dólares que incluyen
bonos y subsidios laborales ya lo decía
usted está jorge y lo hablamos en la
parte de noticias de este programa sobre
ese corte de gas que va a recibir
alemania por el mantenimiento que le van
a hacer a la línea 1 del norte stream
entonces aquí queda la pregunta de si
esto puede prolongarse en el tiempo y
alemania puede haber un corte de gas más
largo bueno este gasoducto transporte el
gas ruso directamente alemania y aunque
la causa del corte es mantenimiento
berlín considera que el kg de gas está
siendo utilizado por el kremlin para
ejercer presión política hay temor
porque el tránsito del gas ruso a través
de polonia ya se ha interrumpido y los
que pasan por ucrania también se han
visto reducidos por la guerra la mitad
de los horas es hogares alemanes
dependen de la calefacción de gas sobre
todo en octubre a marzo pero si el
gasoducto no se reabre no se podrían
llenar los depósitos de gas subterráneo
antes del invierno es el gran temor
muchas gracias jorge por esta
información punto final la economía a
continuación del debate
[Música]